pour 270 contre
265 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté en conséquence le projet de loi
est
[Musique]
rejeté c'est toutes les avan nous av
disparaî voter cette motion de rejet
c'est seulement mais nettement
reconnaître la situation politique et
parlementaire telle qu'elle est c'est
dire que ce débat sur la France
sur sa place dans le monde sur le
rapport que la République entretient à
celles et à ceux qui la rejoignent quoi
que l'on pense sur le fond mérite mieux
que vos tergiversations que vos
gesticulations et que quelques trahisons
Ernest trenant écrivait que ce qui
constitue une nation ce n'est pas de
parler la même langue ou d'appartenir à
un groupe ethnographique commun c'est
d'avoir fait ensemble de grandes choses
dans le passé et de vouloir en faire
encore dans l'avenir alors je dis pour
ma part pour ma part que nous sommes une
nation bien plus grande bien plus forte
bien plus belle que l'idée que s'en font
les partisans du repli identitaire et
nationaliste nous ne sommes qu'au début
de la grande aventure qui'est la France
je n'ai pas peur du débat parce que vous
savez il y a des millions de Français
qui regardent les débats que nous
avons des millions et des millions qui
vont voir les députés du rassemblement
national et certains députés des
républicains voter avec Monsieur Lucas
qui veut la régularisation de tous les
sans papierers les Français doivent
comprendre une partie de la droite va
voter à qui décide désormais hors du
champ républicain cette motion rime avec
irresponsabilité
irresponsabilité car son adoption
priverait la représ représentation
nationale d'un débat qui quel qu'en soit
l'issue est indispensable et souhaité
par les Français
irresonsabilité car son adoption
priverait l'état de nouveaux moyens pour
choisir qui est en droit de séjourner
sur notre territoire et à quelles
condition l'immigration est un sujet de
préoccupation majeure de nos concitoyens
qui est trop souvent au Tage de
l'affrontement entre deux ou trans d'une
part l'immigration zéro d'un côté ce
mythe qui nous est évidemment évoqué
très souvent par l'extrême droite de
l'autre l'ouverture totale des
frontières complètement irresponsable
pourtant pourtant ce sujet appelle de
notre part une grande responsabilité et
malheureusement ces deux outrances nous
privent finalement d'une parole qui soit
responsable maîtrisée mesuré et apaiser
sur un sujet aussi complexe monsieur le
ministre vos provocations au-delà de
faire éclater au grand jour les
divergences qui fracturent votre
majorité et votre fébrilité sont
indécentes elles sont indécentes parce
que quand on appartient à un
gouvernement à ce point adepte des 493
on ne vient pas donner des leçon de
démocratie
elles sont indécentes car quand on a
votre bilan 120 attaques au couteau par
jour un taux d'exécution des des octf
qui n'atteint même pas les 7 % des
subventions aux associations
immigrationnistes qui qui frôle le
milliard d'euros entre 600000 et 900000
clandestins qui vivent sur notre sol et
plus de 400000 étrangers légaux qui
entrent en France chaque année on ne
vient pas donner des leçons en matière
de protection des Français une loi C
news construite par un ministre
d'extrême droite une loi rédigée autour
de la théorie du grand emplacement
théorie raciste et complotiste utilisée
par l'extrême droite pour commettre des
tueres de masse monsieur le ministre
nous le répéterons à chaque fois il n'y
a pas de vagues migratoir incontrôlé en
France il y a une crise de l'accueil
malheureusement votre gouvernement a
laissé piétiner en commission des lois
le texte issu du Sénat le texte de
fermeté issu du Sénat ici même la
semaine dernière votre gouvernement a
refusé à balayer d'un revers de la main
la proposition de réarmement juridique
de notre pays proposée par Eric CTI à
travers une modification de la
constitution ou par Michel Tabarot à
travers la dénonciation de l'accord de
196 suite les Français attendent un
changement attendent un changement
radical mais le texte sorti de la
commission des lois est une fausse
promesse